foreign
Jake is with us Jake's in Orlando
Florida hi Jake what's up
hey good afternoon thanks for taking my
call sure I had a I had a game had a
game plan I wanted to run by I know I
could count on you to tell me if there's
a stupid butt idea or not
um
so I love you and I'll tell you the
truth
yes sir absolutely uh got 50 000 in
Consumer Debt
um I've been putting back this last year
for retirement
um I've got about 50 000 in retirement
accounts uh I've got 220 in student
loans
and I have a house
um that I could sell for five roughly
five and I owe 280 on that's your
personal residence
yes sir you're a doctor or a lawyer
uh I'm anesthesia good pharmacist yeah
okay thank God so you're making what
quarter million yeah
um
190 with uh overtimes 260 270. almost
like I've done this before okay yeah
right all right and what does she make
she stays at home with the kids okay
I've got a five-year-old and a
three-year-old
okay um what's your plan
so I'm thinking about taking the what's
in their retirement accounts wiping out
the Consumer Debt uh and selling the
house and wiping out with student loans
uh renting for a year saving the 20 for
the next house and doing things right
moving forward I don't I don't know if
it's a quick hit reset button or suck it
up and buckle down a focus yeah I got
you
well I appreciate your motivation you're
willing to do whatever it takes that's
pretty cool not many people are yes uh
but you don't hate your house and
neither does your wife
we love the house okay okay so I almost
never sell the house if I can avoid it
as advice okay it's uh if you can't
afford it we're going to get rid of it
if it's the only way to avoid bankruptcy
we're gonna get rid of it but in your
case you have this huge hole that you're
in and you have this fabulously large
shovel
right so no I'm gonna in order to keep
the house though the family is going to
commit to a couple of three years of
beans and rice and no vacations
no lifestyle we're not living like a
rich doctor because we're not we're a
broke doctor
right so no and you never cash out your
retirement to pay off debt unless it's
to avoid bankruptcy or unless you have
you know two million dollars and you're
68 years old you know how many penalties
we might do it then but not now we're
not doing this with penalties so stop
adding to retirement get on a beans and
rice budget the two of you commit to
completely cleaning up all of your 270
000 worth of debt with your 250 000
income so let's say we did 90 a year
that's three years
yes sir and that's what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes uh because it sets
you free for the rest of your life then
uh to to invest and with this fabulous
income and your income's not going to do
anything but go up you're not been out
that long
and how old are your kids again
uh five and three perfect so let me tell
you on the back end of this what this
looks like um your two little kids are
gonna get to watch you
um struggle and make do and y'all make
dinner at home even when you're tired
and they're gonna take some incredible
lessons from this they're gonna change
them forever and so I would tell you
don't Rob them of a three-year learning
opportunity watching their dad and mom
do really hard things
they get to watch these things and be
great